la première élection municipale le débat
[Musique]
bienvenue bienvenue dans ce nouveau
débat des élections municipales et
communautaires sur martinique la
première consacrée pour cette édition à
la ville de schoelcher avec quatre
listes en lice à l'heure nous parlons
car rappelons que nous sommes en pleine
période d'enregistrement officiel des
listes en préfecture
alors nous avons autour de la table de
notre studio les quatre candidats têtes
de liste et avec jean-marc parti qui
animera avec moi bien nous vous les
présentons sans plus tarder mais voilà
nous avons un bon soir à tout bon soir à
tous et bienvenue sur notre antenne
radio et sur notre site internet que
vous retrouvez jusqu'à l'avant-veille du
scrutin donc jusqu'au 13 mars prochain
vous pouvez retrouver cette vidéo alors
tout d'abord parmi les 4 mai les quatre
candidats par ordre alphabétique daniel
chomet le bonsoir on est chaud mais bon
soit aux auditeurs de notre première et
où singulièrement à ses deux chiens vous
avez cinq hommes deux ans vous êtes
professeur c'est quand je vous ai
vieilli volontairement 51 ans vous aurez
50 dès l'année prochaine
professeur de physique vous mener la
liste celle chirens dynamique et
solidaire je rappelle que vous avez été
conseiller régional de 2010 à 2015 à
notre table également lu clémente et
maire sortant âgé de 65 ans cadres de
direction d'établissement bancaire vous
êtes sans retraite et vous menez la
l'union la liste l'union avec vivre
achète cher
on rappelle que vous êtes troisième vice
président de la cacem président de
l'établissement public foncier local
vous avez été conseiller général entre
1998 et 2010 et conseiller régional
entre 2010 et 2015
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bonsoir
valentino valentin à côté de monsieur
clémente et se trouve monsieur franck
sainte-rose heureusement bonsoir
monsieur s'est heureusement
bonsoir bonsoir à tous ou celle chinoise
et aux chevrons vous êtes âgé de 50 ans
nous exercer le métier de cadre de la
fonction publique territoriale et vous
animez la liste les ateliers celle sur
les citoyens cherchent et citoyen
qu'analyste voilà et puis quatrième
candidate donc marine et de torpilles
bonsoir vous êtes âgé de 60 ans courtier
d'assurances de profession vous êtes à
la tête de la liste réussir chaque
chaire autrement déjà conseillère
municipale d'opposition membres du
conseil exécutif de la ctm en charge du
développement économique
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bon soir
particulièrement cherché oise et
hocheich loi voilà alors avant que
jean-marc partie nous présente en
quelques lignes la ville de schoelcher
je voudrais vous faire réagir
chacune et chacun a une actualité
alors vous allez le faire de manière
assez courtes s'il vous plaît puisque
vous le savez le temps nous est compté
cette actualité en rapport direct avec
l'élection la campagne électorale donc
pour ces élections municipales et
communautaires et avec donc le retrait
du candidat benjamin griveaux candidat
de la république en marche qui donc
ambitionnait d'être maire de paris
pourquoi pas il a dû donc annoncé son
retrait aujourd'hui suite à la
publication sur les réseaux sociaux donc
d'un document le un peu compromettants
pour lui on va dire et donc il a été
poussé très vite
enfin il a pris la décision très vite
d'arrêter qu'est ce que cela vous donne
à réagir notamment par rapport à la
campagne électorale sur donc les réseaux
sociaux marina torpille basque est ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que aujourd'hui
les réseaux sociaux font partie d'un
arsenal je dirais très comme une arme
quoi ça peut ça peut vous descendre
quand parce que quand on voit tout ce
qu'on peut passer sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya des choses qui sont
intéressantes et puis il ya des choses
aussi qui sont très malheureuse et
qu'ils font des fois très mal et pour
pouvoir supporter de des fois des propos
ou des images ccc difficile et les
réseaux sociaux font partie je dirais de
national
de d'armes qui peuvent être utilisés à
manier avec beaucoup de précaution
utilisé à mauvais escient la plupart du
temps à une arme généralement c'est
n'est pas utilisé à bon escient
daniel chomet voilà alors on me rappelle
que c'est il ya une atteinte à la vie
privée un clairement de ceux de cet ex
candidats à travers de communication
réseaux sociaux cela est inquiétant et
l'airé nature d'une forme une tendance
en politique qui qui devenu un espace
très violent et les réseaux sociaux ne
facilite pas la tâche puisqu'ils
permettent dans l'anonymat de cracher
toute forme d' insulte et de porter
atteinte à la vie privée des uns et des
autres cela est très grave et je pense
que cela doit amener chaque individu
chaque citoyen s'interroger sur son
usage des réseaux sociaux mais surtout
sur la façon de concevoir l'action
publique pour pas que ça devienne une
arène ce n'est qu'un débat politique ce
n'est qu'une élection est rien le mérite
une telle violence froid que 5,3
heureusement juste vous signaler que là
ce n'est pas une attaque anonyme puisque
l'auteur non je pense général seven
l'auteur de cette vidéo anonyme je le
rappelle pour les audiences je les
informe pour ceux qui n'ont pas entendu
effectué leurs premiers à revendiquer
sans alors que plusieurs médias
une subtilité tout de même 1 avant que
vous répondiez c'est que il dit que
c'est lui qui l'a publié mais il a
peut-être reçu de quelqu'un d'autre et
donc le candidat l'ex candidat de toute
façon a décidé qu'il portera plainte en
justice
et je pense qu'ils vont tenter de
remonter à l'origine a vraiment à celui
qui initialement au sel qui à l'auteur
voilà parce que c'est peut-être
l'artiste russe en question n'est
peut-être qu'un relayeur finalement
franck sainte-rose heureusement oui moi
je écoutez moi je condamne fermement ces
attaques à la vie personnelle
néanmoins parce qu'il ya néanmoins les
choses seraient peut-être plus facile si
monsieur vivo avait fait preuve de
d'exemplarité et je crois que il faut
qu'il y ait une adéquation entre les
valeurs que vous portez et l'action que
vous menez est l'image que vous renvoyez
voilà c'est la manière la plus simple
d'éviter d'être attaqué même si la taxe
n'est pas je le répète justifié et c'est
ainsi que nous citoyens celle çi roi
nous concevons les choses nous voulons
de l'éthique dans notre démarche
politique on n'est pas encore dans le
débat répond à ma manière
oui nous voulons non pas vanter leur
liste donc voilà ok donc on doit tracer
nécessaire bon ben voilà oui de
l'éthique on a bien compris c'est ce que
vous voulez défendre
enfin mathieu que le matin lui que
clémente et qu'est-ce que vous inspire
cette cette information
oui sur peut dire sur le sujet c'est que
l'une des grandes tendances aujourd'hui
de la vie politique
c'est une sorte d'intrusion finalement
dans la vie personnelle à la vie privée
c'est vrai que c'est gênant c'est
évident pourquoi parce que ce type
d'attitude qui correspond quelque part
une sorte de revers de l'utilisation
massive des réseaux sociaux peut quelque
pas mettre en cause est un péril voire
même commandé à la la démocratie c'est
ma grosse crainte c'est ma grosse claque
là dessus il ne ce point de vue on ne
peut que condamner cette forme de
violence parce que c'en est une c'est
tout à fait ça est appelée qu'on puisse
dans le cadre des élections quelle
qu'elle soit locale nationale européenne
je ne sais trop trouvé l'art et la
manière de mettre en place une sorte de
code déontologique de connectique
permettant d'éviter ce type de dérapage
merci donc à vous tous et vient
maintenant donc jean-marc partie
en quelques lignes la fiche essentiel de
cette ville dont qui d'ailleurs n'a pas
toujours porté ce nom de famille d'un
illustre homme français oui en effet et
d'ailleurs c'est la seule ville qui
porte le nom de victor schoelcher un
artisan majeur de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé comme le sait puisque la
ville s'appelait jusqu'en 1889 15
navires du nom donné par les premiers
colons de leur établissement sur la côte
caraïbe la martinique un procès qui ne
le savent pas qu'une oubliée c'est quand
on vient de fort de france qu'on va vers
le nom car il chez le chien c'est la
première ville que l'on rencontre c'est
inclus que sont la porte du nom caraïbes
et cela avant d'arriver à case-pilote je
rappelle que c'est la quatrième commune
la plus peuplée de martinique après
feront de france comme on le sait
lamentin et robin jean lesieur compte un
peu plus de 20000 habitants un chiffre
était passé déjà depuis une vingtaine
d'années donc c'est plus ou moins vingt
à vingt-deux mille habitants depuis 25
ans pour cette villa située à la
périphérie immédiate de fort de france
c'est une commune assez particulière
parce qu'elle est très fortement
urbanisée avec par exemple la cité
ozanam rabatelière mais également t en
ville sur les hauteurs ravine tout ça où
se situe d'ailleurs le campus
universitaire et vous alors des
quartiers comme la colline plus récent
la langue à ce pilote sans oublier
madiana et puis il ya le bon
traditionnel de dimensions très modeste
presque entièrement est parti sur l'a40
y ait de la spa dames et chez le chien
comprend également des quartiers
populaires en plus traditionnels comme
fond de laillé fonds bernier ou la
démarche on pas entendu bon en à
l'enlever en case pilote
je rappelle que les électeurs devant et
lyon 35 conseillers ou conseillères
municipaux municipal dont sept délégués
à la casse m
sur les 56 membres que compte cette
institution compte de très nombreux
équipements de santé de culture
d'éducation pour ses habitants et aussi
pour ceux qui y passent ou qui y
travaillent enfin c'est une ville très
sportive avec entre autres le club de
football de l'émulation qui a des
fortunes diverses depuis quelques temps
le club nautique de chercheurs le cns
qui a produit des quantités de grands
nageurs et de grandes nageuses le
martinique université club le muc en
handball c'est ce sont ces tensions ou
des étudiants mais pas qu'eux qui
pratiquent cette discipline là haut sur
le campus et puis la célébrissime à
scotia qui a produit tant de champion
des champions en athlétisme
et puis je termine avec le club d'aviron
à ses 233 avec son célèbre gommier
francs pdl au palmarès impressionnant
mais
qui n'est pas forcément plus fort que
les goumiers de carbeo vous êtes seul
responsable de vos propos me supporter
ah bon alors gel cher ex 15 navires donc
ou bien qu'à quartetto notre consoeur
s'est rendu donc un reportage un micro
trottoir comme comme on dit afin de
recueillir des sentiments et des avis
d'administrer à quelques semaines à
présent maintenant des échéances
municipales et communautaires on écoute
donc ces quelques habitantes et
habitants de chercheurs il m'a beaucoup
de choses et en même temps il manque une
y est je trouve que cette ville est
entre deux paires donc largement sa
qualité de vie ce n'est les réverbères
et à l'espagne on vous dit qu'il n'y a
pas d'argent pour changer quelques
ampoules il n'y a pas de rechange
il a fallu que les élections approchent
vous qu'à partir du rond-point de
l'enclos on décide de refaire un petit
peu l'asphalté à réparer les routes ça
serait bien passé les trous par exemple
de la piscine municipale
c'est pas trop ça vous avez un collège
là où la route est complètement défoncée
c'est du n'importe quoi il faut arrêter
de construire n'importe quoi il faut
arrêter de construire pour les gens qui
viennent spéculer j'essaie de retrouver
donc ce qui reste encore un petit peu de
nature l'émission qui était prévu qu'
une mise à l'eau pour que les
aberrations puis salembien n'existe
toujours pas il dynamise la ville pour
les jeunes est en train de se calmer et
de boire de l'alcool à tout bout de
champ la de l'après-midi alors qu'en
fait on aurait plus préféré se retrouver
là à l'activité des podiums enfin des
scènes ouvertes auxquelles on pourrait
tous participé j'espère qu'il vaut sur
un peu tous les petits commerçants cole
ou qu'on fait un projet que ça dur dur
dur à long terme tant que chercheur
émérite et vous deviez le casino le
temps pich veille les rectorats le
palais des congrès et ces gens là ont
tendance à venir sur la place ils ont
offert leurs besoins impossible parce
qu'il ait pas de latrines
on est de la quatrième ville de la
martinique ça qui fait fait ça qui va se
passer je m'en tamponne les gens qui
veut avancer la commune
la taille des jacquots petit ou avancer
plus voilà donc
oh toi comme nous disions dans notre
jargon qui n'a pas valeur de sondage
auto répète ce n'est absolument pas une
démarche scientifique simplement un
travail de reporter d'une europe en
crise bien qu'à karité en l'occurrence
qui a été se promener avec son micro ce
matin alors entre de celle chinoise et
de chez le chinois avec des voiliers des
ressentis des points de vue sur la vie
économique sociale ou culturelle
animation de la ville tel hôtel group
l'habitat donc c'est très varié marina
tant pis que vous inspirent ces quelques
réactions déjà sa montre et à tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui chercheur une ville
totalement endormie qui où ce moi même
je vois que pas grand chose se passait
en tant que chaîne chinoise depuis douze
ans que vous allez de la colline à
plateaux faut en passant par parle
terville ou bien vous continuez jusqu'à
plateau à et a pas grand chose qui se
passe en termes d'aménagement
l'aménagement et l'équipement même
hérité des mandats précédents sont
totalement à l'abandon ils sont
délaissés le grand bac à sable enfin le
stade de sable comme ça vaut sous lens
madame c'est un dac avira chien bon ok
porté par des chats donc vraiment se
demande qu'est ce qui se passe à
schoelcher alors au niveau même du
personnel quand on regarde les veaux du
personnel nous n'avons pas non plus tant
pis je vous interromps parce que là
c'est une première séquence s'agit de
réagir aux commentaires de ne pas être
trop long on n'est pas encore vraiment
rentré dans le vif du débat que
l'appareil
je reste je reste parce que sur ça voilà
c'est tout il n'y a que par rapport à ce
que vous avez entendu
lucas clementé m'écouter il ya mille
manières de faire micro trottoir en tout
cas la façon dont je vie chère
personnellement et à partir de ce que
j'entends ici et là jamais de dire qu'il
faut être aveugle et sourd pour
prétendre qu'il ne se passe rien à
schoelcher nous avons une animation
territoriale dont la pente du populaire
diversifiée et je me réfère à une seule
chose puisque nous sommes en live
actuellement à la présentation de
chamakh parti
ils étaient dithyrambiques
si la vision de la vie de celle cher à
beaucoup d'égards je me réfère à ce que
marine est autorisé à l'instant tous les
samedis je fais mon amour à celle cheikh
fall avait précisément je pense un et
j'en suis particulièrement fier vétérans
2 133 ça me suffit et j'ai envie de dire
il d'ajouter que au plan culturel
nous avons des animations
particulièrement importante cherchait
qu'à songer car le dispositif cargo lors
dans la ville le village musical anti
moment sous et anti mon grand plaisir
l'école de musique le théâtre israël
pour les jeunes enfants n'en est pas
encore à votre ville en est jeté a mené
juste cela dieu a besoin que si avec ça
on considère que chez le chien est une
ville endormie
je veux dire que nous avions peut-être
pas dans une ville et qu'il serait temps
pour ceux qui le saut des puces se
réveiller merci dans cette réaction est
clémente et mais en sortant des chaînes
cher en fait franks à trois mouvements
que vous inspire ce que vous avez
entendu écouté je crois que ça
correspond à la à la réalité que les
chefs chinois vivent
monsieur clémente et à sa réalité à lui
on s'en aperçoit depuis quelques temps
les chaînes xinhua ont une autre réalité
qu'ils vivent et c'est un bilan qui est
qui est plutôt sombre que les gens
dépeignent là il manque des choses ce
qui ne fonctionne pas bien
malgré tout on peut en parler nous
sommes d'accord la journaliste n'est pas
de faire un bilan de la mandature grade
non non c'est pas ça c'est en tout cas
le bilan que nous faisons nous puisque
notre mouvement à nous et aux mouvements
de simples habitants de celle cher c'est
celui qu'on a entendu là c'est un bilan
qui est plutôt sombre où le quartier
plutôt sombre pour la plupart des
chaînes shirwa pas tous c'est vrai qu'il
y en a qui sont mieux traités que
d'autres
et puis c'est un bilan sombre pour le
personnel dans votre présentation
monsieur parenti vous avez oublier deux
choses importantes qui me tiennent en
tout cas à coeur vous avez nommés les
quartiers vous n'êtes pas exhaustive je
ne sers à tous les quartiers mais vous
n'avez pas nous mais le quartier fonds
d'atelier quartier emblématique de chêne
cher qui est un quartier traditionnel
d'habitat spontané et dont nous voulons
préserver l'authenticité c'était pour
autant et puis vous n'avez pas mentionné
non plus une nouvelle équipe qui
s'appelle les marrons le chef cheikh qui
est une équipe de futsal qui monte et
qui est très bien classé au championnat
martinique qui ont pu parler pendant une
heure le temps de chercher à sauver
votre commentaire je rassure tout le
monde l'échelle chinois ne sont pas
endormis sont ni aveugles sourds et sont
extrêmement lucide il parle avec leur
coeur et je crois que le constat est
sans appel d'une ville qui tente pas le
d'initiative il le dit chacun à leur
manière
pas de mise à l'eau pas de l'association
pas d'autres activités
pas d'initiative dans lesquelles les
jeunes se reconnaissent mais aussi
véritablement l'impression et le
sentiment que on est beaucoup dans
l'opportunisme incite à la veille
d'élections que l'on fait du bitume et
l'on se plaint qu'il n'y a pas d'argent
alors qu'en réalité nous savons tous que
il existe des financements vont prendre
des initiatives mais que c'est sans
doute ça c'est mon explication
personnelle
plusieurs du pouvoir et de ce point de
vue là les chaînes shirwa encore une
fois sont très attentifs et attendent
que l'on oppose qui des vraies solutions
pour demain
alors vous allez pouvoir regarder la
parole parce que maintenant nous
rentrons vraiment dans le vif du débat
avec un premier thème que nous avons
donc sélectionné et le tirage au sort
vous a désigné daniel chomet pour
répondre à la première question
justement dans cette séquence dans cette
partie de notre débat ce premier thème
concerne justement l'aménagement de la
ville l'aménagement l'équipement de la
ville et ces dernières années il y a un
projet déjà bien avancé je crois je sais
pas si ça fait polémique mais en tout
cas tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
notamment chez des habitants de terville
le funérarium de terville qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous le candidat donc
daniel chomet pour ces élections
municipales et communautaires achète
cher pour dire les choses très
simplement puisque nous avons peu de
temps quand on veut lancer un projet de
ce type il faut de la méthode au long
des études de faisabilité d'opportunités
pour identifier d'une part où et comment
peut-on faire de tels projets qui
amènent des flux et des personnes nous
sommes là dans l'initiative qui a été
prise par cette équipe dans le dos des
habitants sans consultation sans
discussion en train de constater qu'il y
a le projet qui est en phase finale
puisque il ya des marchés qui sont pas
c'est qu'aux réalisations et en
conception alors que loue des données
d'entrée sur lesquels on aurait dû se
pencher c'est la question de la
circulation
la voix de terville et une voix enclavé
la promesse électorale qui avait été
donnée il ya 12 ans n'a pas été tenue et
il ya un vrai problème de sécurité
dans ces conditions j'ai du mal à
comprendre et l'ensemble des habitants
de thierville de l'enclos ont du mal à
le comprendre l'ensemble pas l'ensemble
on aura beaucoup ne comprennent pas il
s'agit pas de de prendre ses supporters
et d'en faire des gens qui valide une
option c'est pas ça je vous dis qu'il ya
là peu tir de la population de chats les
chiens qui est exposé à un risque et un
funérarium est proposé sans traiter la
question de fond qui est celle de la
circulation
donc je pense qu'il ya là une
défaillance totale et nous avons de ce
point de vue une autre approche
hh ya dynamique et solidaire quand ils
vont voir de vouloir prendre au moins le
soin de l'examen avant d'imposer des
décisions de ce type aux habitants arina
tant pis fallait-il ou pas construire un
finira à schoelcher et en particulier là
où il est prévu
interview alors vous savez depuis 2014
en 2014 je me suis présenté j'avais un
programme est dans mon programme
il était prévu un funérarium à
schoelcher donc tout ça pour dire que le
funérarium hr je suis pour je pense que
nous avons besoin de cet équipement
mais là où monsieur clémentes et veulent
eux placés là c'est ça pose problème
et comme il a été dit on un problème de
voirie
on avait un problème de stationnement on
a un problème de mise en sonore on ne
peut pas mettre le funérarium là où il
est et en plus de ça aux ondes en
hauteur il est moins pertinent de le
mettre là il est préférable de le mettre
dans la partie basse pour une personne
par exemple je les dis dernièrement on
peut le mettre dans la zone d'activité
qui va se fier à case navire pourquoi
pas on peut mettre aussi sur un terrain
qu'on a face au au collège vincent
placoly pourquoi pas aimé il y a
d'autres aussi d'autres emplacements qui
ce cas intéressant en fait tous à
produire de rapprocher les bons puisque
j'y vais
dubourg maintenant un axe passant est
donc depuis 2014 ce funérarium aurait
déjà dû être fait et on voit dans une
précipitation qu'on ne se explique pas
c'était une agitation
on a un appel d'offres qui est lancée
sur le france antilles pour pouvoir
choisir une entreprise en possession une
réalisation en septembre et ensuite on
fait une réunion de consultation de la
population en novembre en fait bon de
qui on se moque en fait il ya un vrai
problème est donc ce funérarium là où il
est là où il est prévu
ça ne peut pas se faire à cet endroit
c'est singer vient d'engager un
manifestement donc nous allons demander
son avis au regard des chercheurs le
clémente et qui est là avec nous
justement alors ça finira raymond fruits
frais de la tension une polémique une
controverse en tout cas faisant pour une
méthode première question le funérarium
est il nécessaire à schoelcher à
l'unanimité oui urgent qu'on arrête de
parasites et fort de france et d'obliger
les grandes personnes de chercheurs à la
veillée assez loin de leur ville
deuxième question un funérarium c'est à
dire des salles de veiller est ce la
même chose que crématorium non finis
royaume
c'est une salle de veiller c'est tout
cependant je dois admettre que la
population doit être absolument rassurer
sur un certain nombre de points
quels sont ses points ces points semble
le fait que par exemple 0 reproché de ne
pas avoir consulté la population j'y
arrive
yat il y aura-t-il assez places de
parkings très largement nous allons
passer quelque chose comme 200 places de
parking c'est à dire autant de places de
parking pour deux salles de veiller
qu'il y en a à fort de france pau quatre
salles de veiller dans une très grande
salle veillée ça c'est la première
question alors qu'il fait autant faut-il
consulter la population
mais bien sûr que oui lavaud consultés
lors de notre 500 deuxième réunion de
quartier en mer d'où lui avait plus de
100 personnes
c'est urgent de le faire troisième
question lorsqu'on consulte une
population on va véritablement que mes
adversaires
on peut la pratiquer dans les mocratie
participative
on ne va pas la fleur au fusil là mais
dans les poches en disant on être sûr de
faire ça pour coup qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
non il faut des documents il faut dix
esquisse comme cela se passe d'ailleurs
pour comment dire le viaduc de foyers
jusqu'à présent la population n'a rien
vu de concret de la fabrique à laquelle
appartient ma concurrente
comment dire je peux comprendre ça
puisqu'il faut bien qu'ils viennent en
laisse qui s'en viennent
tous deux viennent dans la population
avec des éléments à partir desquels on
discute le viaduc de faladié juste pour
nos auditeurs et internautes c'est le
projet de loi sur la maîtrise et non pas
par la mairie s'est même pas importante
des prix de plus de cv ça lots de cette
consultation
nous avons reçu une réponse que nous
allons soumettre à la population et on
décidera ensemble du comment faire les
choses et là dessus
la boucle se chercher à toujours été
habitué à cela d'ailleurs le de mes
concurrents a mobilisé par le journal
par les réseaux sociaux pour une
manifestation il y avait cette personne
ne met aucune autre pareille très peu
non mais j'ai fait une pétition je suis
à 400 signatures de ces dans cette
pétition à dire j'ai eu autant de
signatures sur internet que des
signatures physique en honneur et nous
lancer à la population mais ça fait
partie des méthodes du nez en sortant de
transformer les réalités à ça à sa guise
et franck centre heureusement à propos
de ce projet qui n'est plus d'ailleurs
qu'un projet c'est un projet bien bien
bien démarré d'après ce qu'on comprend
du ce funérarium au quartier et terville
tout à fait c'est un projet
malheureusement bien démarrer moi je
crois que oui chez a besoin d'eau
funérarium j'avais une grande ville et
il a besoin de finir orium notre méthode
à nous c'est de proposer à la population
des scénarii voilà maintenant qu'il ya
parlé tout à l'heure de l'espace qui
aurait pu accueillir cet équipement
c'est vrai il en existe et nous voulons
nous proposer à la population des
scénarii mais au delà
au delà nous c'est la question sur votre
méthode parce que c'est important
vous dites que vous voulez proposer des
scénarii oui donc c'est une consultation
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont ils vont voter
c'est mais qui décide c'est de la
population ou c'est là la municipalité
le maire
nous avons des outils plusieurs outils
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure de
démocratie participative réel oui qui
peuvent être des référendums
d'initiative locale qui peuvent être des
consultations des habitants du ou des
quartiers les plus impactés oui la
population doit se prononcer sur des
propositions
bon ça c'est la première chose mais ce
qui me paraît aussi important c'est le
financement de cet équipement
on est dans une équipe municipale qui se
plaît en permanence du manque d'argent
et qui à la première occasion engage des
fonds puisqu'ils étaient des
consultations d'entreprises ça veut dire
sa vision de dieu qu'il est prêt à
dépenser de l'argent au lieu de proposer
en tout cas nous c'est la solution que
nous pensons la plus adaptée de proposer
à des entreprises l'anti nicaise de
porter ce projet et de le et de le
rentabiliser
à travers des locations de salles ce que
ce qui ce qui va se faire mais mais mais
qui sera d'abord porté par les finances
municipales
voilà nous n'avons cette approche-là de
ce projet voulait dire a ajouté les
planches passe à autre chose parce qu il
nous faut donc daniel chomette le rajout
comme le disait front sainte-rose
heureusement pour pouvoir identifier les
scénarios quand les gens sont sérieux
ils font ce qu'on appelle une étude de
faisabilité et cela aurait permis
d'identifier par exemple le point que
proposait madame torpille ou un autre
rookie sage et c'est sur la base de ces
éléments là qu'on va vers la population
ce n'est pas ce qui s'est passé
la mairie de chercheur et son équipe a
décidé tout seul
de là où ça se ferait comment ça se
ferait et vient consulter la population
sur le choix de la couleur
et la taille des gars vous donc nous
confier tout sauf de la démocratie par
des mâchoires si terville pour
l'implantation de ce funérarium
simplement lui clementé et je vais
vendre appuyé sur ma collègue au conseil
municipal actuel la ville de cherchell
et orbi que feu monsieur bertrand le
nommer prédécesseur et dans la suite
par la suite monsieur allemands montent
ou direct prédécesseur avait prévu le
format du cimetière de thierville pour
accueillir justement ce type de comédie
relais fois structure d'équipement c'est
de ça qu'il s'agit
et à y réfléchir bien quand on se
prétend être un docte un référent en
matière de commandes ird et d'écologie
aujourd'hui la grande tendance dans le
monde entier et d'éviter ce qu'on
appelle l'artificialisation des sols
c'est à dire le fait de rendre permet
imperméable et seul toutes les femmes
disposent d'infrastructures sur lesquels
nous pouvons continuer à optimiser les
activités il faut le faire à terville
nous avons les places de parking
bessière les bulles l'emplacement pour
le faire et c'est vrai qu'il faudra dans
le même temps mettre en place un projet
qui me tient à coeur particulièrement
pour les gens que terville la route de
délestage de terme n'en parlera
peut-être tle oui oui ça sur un
emplacement on va et permet à briser la
construction ou supposer qu'elle sera
passée au vert viable madame messieurs
vous pensez bien qu'on ne va pas parler
du film ne cherche uniquement dans
l'émission justement vous avez parlé de
il y a
avec l'importance de la population et
des personnes qui travaillent notamment
rectorat et de là dans la zone problème
de classement quasiment puisque à une
seule voie de desserte pour un pour y
entrer et puis pour moi surtout bons
sentiments pour ceux qui résident c'est
très compliqué bon vous a donné lecture
de l'écologie qui est assez étroite
alors comment est ce qu'on va faire
comme coeur le chemin pour une v5 la vt
envie de ça veut dire qu'encore une fois
depuis 12 ans aucune initiative n'était
prise par le maire en place pour faire
avancer de ce dossier ils prétendent
même que le classement de
l'environnement est un frein cela est
faux cela est faux c'est un mensonge la
rivière aujourd'hui qui est une rivière
que l'on peut classer de catégorie 1 ou
2 permet la mise en place d'ouvragés
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas choisi leurs
divers environnements et personnes il
s'agit de concilier une réalité c'est
l'exposition à un risque qui est un
risque majeur qui doit nécessiter qu'il
ait des dispositions qu'ils soient
prises ces dispositions n'ont pas été
prises telles que louis viat s'agit-il
pour accueillir quinze navires qui est
andin partie basse de celle cher et qui
pour certains encore une fois c'est l'un
des scénarios
quand je serai élu si je le suis je
lancerai toutes les études pour
identifier tous les scénarios possibles
il y aura des contraintes à lever il y
aura des financements à identifier parce
qu'il s'agit d'un projet dont on parle
aux 10 yens ou en vingtaine ou trentaine
de millions d'euros
et plutôt que de faire une traversée de
fond l'ail et à près de 150 millions
d'euros
moi j'aurais plutôt partisan de
désenclaver terrils voilà quelque chose
de très concret et de très immédiat à
réaliser alors ça que ça se travaille
justement sur le désenclavement de
carburant gardien ferro savait que les
très fortes absolument et erbil c'est le
cheer de la population de chercheurs
donc c'est extrêmement important et
cette population là est coincé avec une
seule voie d'entrée une seule voie de
sortie pour nous il ya deux temps dans
dans des deux manières d'envisager ce
projet là le premier temps c'est enfin
enfin de mettre en oeuvre un projet qui
est dans les tiroirs de la cacem depuis
2002 2002
qui cette voie de désenclavement dondon
dont monsieur clémentine monsieur show
me gêne de parler
il est temps de la mettre en oeuvre
voilà quatre mois
écoutez il faut la poser au maire en
place non plus je ne peux pas comprendre
et si vous êtes merde comme celui ci ou
comme la situation du restaurant blue
fish qui était sur le front de mer
on reste douze ans dans l'immobilisme le
plus total voilà ça c'est là ça c'est la
première chose c'est le projet
structurant il faut le mener à bien la
deuxième chose nous avons nous citoyens
giroix une solution de transition qui
est la création d'un giratoire au pied
de l'enclos voilà on doive une sortie de
l'enclos qui part derrière font la
guerre c'est cette solution qu'il faut
adopter c'est une solution qui sera mise
en oeuvre en lien avec la ctm puisque
nous sommes sur une route nationale et
qui va permettre de soulager un peu le
trafic est de permettre d évacuation en
cas de danger si vous avez une wii sur
une solution il faut faire cette seconde
voie de terville et y'a pas bhl bien sûr
il n'y a pas de problème de financement
je veux simplement dire tous les toutous
les financements dont on a besoin
au niveau d'une commune qui a je dirais
qu est normalement qui a des capacités
d'investissement sont sont assez
importants les financements qui sont à
disposition
vous pouvez être financée par la ctn
part du fait d un parent du fait amp par
le contrat convergence ou déposer un
dossier par le fmi le fonds exceptionnel
d'investissement
vous avez la ds et lycées la dotation
spécifique d'investissement local vous
avez la detr c'est la dotation
d'équipement des territoires où vous
avez la banque des territoires c'est la
cdc vous avez tout le temps mais non
jours a terminé les landes et les appels
à projets européens les appels à projets
nationaux tout ça pour dire que vous
avez vous avez un arsenal possible pour
une commune comme celle cher de faire de
l'investissement sur des projets qui
sont structurants et qui peuvent donc la
voie de la moindre degré enclavement de
terville droite extrême ça fait plus de
12 ans qu'on l'attend il est en effet le
mois merde
matin je la ferai alors le projet du
rond point on est à côté donc je veux
bien mais en fait dans 10 ans mais oui
mais ce qui va se faire dans deezer avec
l'expérience on le sait là haut on ne
fait peur on pourrait comme ça en cinq
ans on est là pour remettre dans dix
quinze ans peut-être vous mais non c'est
non mais je suis sûr de ça c'est le
temps de faire l'étude d'impact la
faisabilité tout on fait les choses
sérieusement
on aura en sera pour dix ans donc cette
route de terrain ville qui aujourd'hui
il ya toutes les conditions pour la
faire il ya des financements pour la
faire eh bien faisons là était le clou
ils ont clémente et qu'est ce qui
explique que vous ne l'ayez pas eu
recours à ces dispositifs à ces outils à
cet arsenal que vient de m
la marine a torpillé j'avoue ne voulait
pas faire ou vous ne savez pas faire
c'est une question déjà je me réjouis de
réaliser que on a fait un pas
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous au niveau
du candidat d'accord pour dire que il
reconnaît que c'est une vie
communautaire
ça c'est déjà un grand pas de fait
deuxième chose entre communautaire c'est
une de ces nouvelles que nous recevons
de la casse n
deuxième chose est ce une priorité c'est
une très grande priorité mais j'aurais
voulu inscrire sa dans un cadre beaucoup
plus large
quel est ce cadre c'est celui du
désenclavement de la ville de schoelcher
nous avons entrepris ce désenclavement
avec le dire clairement au nord de celle
cher en faisant débouché dimanche sur
citronnelle casse pilote en cas de
problème on l'a c'est possible d'être
sorti deuxième démarche
un projet qui datait de 55 ans
entendez-vous bien 55 ans le
désenclavement de la partie sud de celle
cher la rd43 et à des quarante quatre
anciennes ou de celle chez route de
cluny c'est une réalité nous l'avons
fait et ce projet datait de monsieur
bertrand le temps public est long le
développement a besoin de temps et
terville sera bien sûr ma très grande
priorité
nous aurons certainement lors de cette
mandature si la population le souhaitent
et le veut la présence de la cacem je
m'y engagerai pour ma part très
fortement c'est au projet de 20 millions
d'euros sur lequel là
la ctm l'europe l'état pour apporter
quelque chose soit 60% de financement et
la ville de schoelcher et la cacem
quelque chose comme 40 ans ce n'était
pas votre priorité alors c'est sécurité
dansaient vous dit que ça va être une
priorité
vous avez parlé d'autre chose que vous
avez fait nous sommes des civils
nous sommes au seuil d'une nouvelle
mandature ce sera une très grande
priorité je vous dit quelque chose
la population de terville nous l'a très
largement rendu nous avons toujours été
d'une manière très confortable à
terville donc dans les sols et dans les
végétaux dans les références qui sont
les nôtres nous savons reconnaître ce
type de paix de choses je suis jamais
ensuite l'état interviendrait émis ont
compris entre autres du monde passera un
autre sujet nous assistons est quelque
chose qui peut delà de la question du
désagrément terville doit été appelés le
téléspectateur voilà un élu qui dit
devons tous c'est une priorité
il rajoute même c'est une très grande
priorité
je connaissais pas ce que sera ce sera
ça serait une grande priorité bonne
nouvelle que c'est comme la blague de
coluche on connaissait la lessive qui
lave et blanc et celle qu'il avait plus
blanc que blanc
comment voulez vous que les citoyens
prennent au sérieux quand nous venons
affirmé qu'après qu'une priorité devient
une grande priorité pour qu on espère
qu'après 18 ans on puisse traiter le
problème
je considère que ce projet l'action qui
a été mené par cette équipe sur ce sujet
est un échec et monsieur le maire
sortant vous vous grandir y est en dix
ans nous avons mal fait on s'y prendra
autrement en niant cette situation en
ayant cela vous vous désespérez des
hommes et des femmes qui considère que
la parole politique a un sens quand une
priorité est une priorité
on la traite en six ans quand dix ans on
n'a pas attendre qu'elles deviennent de
grandes priorités et donner le sentiment
qu'on joue les prolongations
alors disons stop il faut siffler la fin
de la récréation et faire en sorte que
les hommes et les femmes qui traiteront
cette question la traiterons comme une
vraie priorité
allez marine attendu et pour conclure
sur ce sujet juste pour des
entraînements
dans l'énumération des différents
projets de monsieur clément t il a parlé
de la jonction des deux routes
départementales
non non c'est fait il a réalisé il faut
arrêter les songes
il a réalisé juste la fin de la jonction
se croyait pas il ya même des kilomètres
c'est simplement la route qui sort de la
sécurité sociale pour arriver à qui
traverse que qui traverse le disions
donc là mais tout le reste de la voie
était fait dans l'ensemble de
l'aménagement du territoire que nous
avons organisées à l'époque à la mode a
tué au président et qui a donné ce
quartier qui aujourd'hui ou qui reçoit
la sécurité sociale le tribunal
administratif et d'autres logements de
seniors et d'autres logements
résidentiels
donc cette partie de route ça n'a pas du
tout été fait par monsieur clémente est
donc prometteur à césar ce qui
appartient à césar c'est juste le petit
bout de chemin qu'il a fait trois
communes par l'accord de bonn pour
préciser comme amiens tomber vous
faisiez vous étiez adjointe au maire du
maire précédent
alfred almont c'est pourquoi vous parlez
de la mandature précédente
franks entre autres ou du moins je veux
quand même répondre à ce qu'a dit
monsieur clementé et à ce qu'a dit on
aime topi supplémenté nous dit qu'il
veut voir grand
bon moi je trouve que ça prend quand
même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup le temps
et puis à force de vouloir voir grand on
oublie ce qui est à côté de nous quoi
les petites choses donc on voit grand on
ne fait pas grand chose et on oublie les
petites choses même temps il nous dit
que ça prendra dix ans de fait un
giratoire sur la route nationale
moi j'en prends moins moi j'en doute moi
j'en doute j'ai déjà travaillé en
collectivité ça fait 28 ans que je
travaille dans les collectivités j'étais
directeur de cabinet j'étais directeur
général adjoint des travaux de ce type
s'ils sont bien négociés et si on se
consacre à les négocier parce que c'est
ce que je veux dire
il faut que les élus de la ville de
schoelcher ils sont que les élus de la
ville de schoelcher se consacrent à leur
mandat sur son sort à leurs habitants
ici ce qui s'est fait en moins de dix
ans comme incitant au point que c'est
normal 10 ans c'est tout
un autre didier complimenta également si
vous l'aménagement de la ville mais ne
pourront pas il faut que tous les tous
les sujets que nous avions
présélectionnés puisqu'ils sont ce sont
des thèmes de campagne s'est désuni le
centre-ville où la bourde de schoelcher
appelons ça comme vous voulez il y à la
rénovation de la place des arts en qui à
l'époque avait fait jalousie d'envié
comme de meilleurs qu'ils se sont
inspirés pour faire un peu préparé en
commune et qui a pris le large à quelque
sorte
et puis il est tout à côté de la place
des héros qui a la première vient madame
qui souvent à sablé à cause du reflux un
réchauffement climatique le reflet du
sable et ça ça crues des inondations et
ça de très grande gêne pour les habitats
l'on commet en fait il s'agit de revoir
tout
toute cette zone dollar formaté et quand
quasiment une marinade temps pays voilà
là vraiment vous tombez dans le coeur de
mon sujet d'aménagement effectivement -7
7 cette zone toute la partie de la place
des halles et la partie de lens madame
doit être fait
alors effectivement sous la partie où il
ya le restaurant au blue fish mais je
veux faire je veux mettre avec mon
équipe on va mettre donc un jardin
d'enfants pour les entoure de france est
la leur une au menu jardin d'enfants
pour les enfants de moins de 7 ans et
pour qu'ils puissent jouer et en toute
sécurité
de l'autre côté donc les jeunes vont
pouvoir et moins jeunes vont pouvoir
s'adonner à des à des sports comme le
basket et je vais redessiner les
terrains de basket
il y aura aussi du volet bon il est plus
le terrain de volley on va leur faire
aussi et puis bon de l'autre côté à lens
madame le bac à chiens ce que je disais
tout à l'heure en remportant en début de
séance et ben oui il faut il faut
trouver une solution quand même ça c'est
à des années que nous avons ce stade de
sable remplis de vers haché et on s'en
contente de le regarder là je dis ça
fait mal au coeur à tous les parents qui
viennent avec des enfants et qui voit
que rien n'est fait pour aménager cet
espace sur cet espace autour de ceux de
ce stade de biche rumeur que je vais
donc rénové avec mon équipe nous allons
mettre des du mobilier urbain pour créer
des jeux seul y aura de la belote des
échecs un peu comme on fait à central
park vous voyez
donc là nous allons faire tout ça et
c'est logique ce qui fait que ça va ça
va permettre vraiment d'avoir une
animation et créer des tournois était un
quartier intergénérations vraiment de
l'animation aussi du côté des arbres
vous voyez tout ce qui passe que je
conçois question pas ce qui n'est pas le
cas de chacun jean-pierre juste une
chose que des poulaillers acquis boucher
alors hommage est pas encore compris
comment la débauche en ces temps ci on
prend on sent le sable mais sur les
côtés et le sable de temps en temps fin
au fur et à mesure pas de temps en temps
au fur et à mesure et on y descend dans
le lit de la rivière
alors j'ai pas très bien compris
pourquoi on ne sont pas ce sable est
carrément et pour qu'on puisse déboucher
la rivière j'ai pas compris ce ballet de
sable sur les côtés ensuite qu'ils ont
on descend dans l'avenir mais bon le
maire vous le voulez expliquant que tu
es tout à l'heure daniel chopin gagna le
chemin
viparis pour pourquoi ça l'important
c'est cette zone à parce que ça draine
du monde qui n'est pas que de la
relation n'est pas que des chercheurs
parce qu'il ya des gens qui sont attirés
une vive et c'est effectivement pendant
tout ce qui se fait
parce que venir quelques fois s'adonnent
à des activités
peut-être même je sais pas en fins
délictueuses pas toujours très
catholiques on l'a entendue dans le dans
le tableau vous avoir interrogés
disaient quand il désignait là c'était
ma dis bien qu'à quartetto aux abords de
comme si non il ya quelques personnels
il faut faire du littoral de chair au
lieu attractif et qu'on n'oublie pas les
48 auxquelles je suis attaché quelques
fonds d'atelier qui sont aujourd'hui
sont oubliées ou là le programme de
réhabilitation est à l'arrêt n'oublions
pas de l'autre côté à l'extrémité nord
de la ville font bernier qui est une
enclave de quartier extraordinaire avec
des ressources extraordinaires rouler où
il ya une entraide qui est qui est
visible mais aujourd'hui le terrain de
foot sert de site de parking pour les
bateaux et les voitures
on est dans un lieu où la ville a
renoncé à agir ou une médiathèque sert
davantage aux formations qu'à faire
vivre les acteurs qui sont dans ce cas
entier donc repenser le littoral c'est
effectivement lui donner
activité de manière assez évidente comme
le disait madame torpille la plage du
bourg c'est l'anarchie
mettre peu d'ordre pour que les
restaurateurs soit dans le confort et
que les jeunes puissent de manière très
simple participer à ce qui peut être des
loisirs sur le sujet redonner du sens
aux activités de pêche rendent pas
compte ni cette plage à pagny en mise à
l'eau fodé ses bouquets payants tracteur
puyo rentrée plusieurs sorties je pense
à mon ami de deux foyers ou dans l'est
dans les pires conditions
les pêcheurs se dépassent ceux des pâtis
vous parliez de m on se sent enfin on se
vante d'avoir des stations nautiques
on combat 11 municipal dans son équipe
mais à les voir dans quelles conditions
le matériel est entreposé
donc il faut reprendre tout cela de
manière très concrète pour donner
effectivement le véritable sens à ce
littoral où des jeunes charles sirois
aurait pu devenir de jeunes
restaurateurs de jeunes entrepreneurs
qu'il n'y a pas d'accompagnement
il n'y a pas de volonté il n'a pas
d'orientation et ses financements qui
existe la ville de schoelcher l'une des
villes qui utilisent vous inclure les
lèvres mais commune donc faire que
l'anversois de l'activité des loisirs
mais aussi une vraie stratégie pour que
cette façade devienne véritablement la
fierté de notre commune fera que ça sent
vraiment sûr hermange mende en fait dans
moi moi je me sens à la fois de ce
domaine public de la façade maritime
mais aussi des inondations voilà qui
sont quand même un fléau qui frappe
schelcher de manière régulière le
domaine public ça fait 12 ans qu'il est
abandonné et que nos places sont décrits
pis aujourd'hui les espaces pour les
enfants sont ouvertes à tous les vents
et les animaux viennent faire leurs
besoins
à côté du petit parc pour les poules et
poulets tout petit voilà les lumières
meurent les unes après les autres
j'ai déjà parlé de l'exemple de blue
fish nous notre projet c'est toujours de
consulter la population alors on le fait
déjà puisque nous sommes sur le terrain
les jeunes attendent que nous
installions la roller park skate park
ils attendent que que qu'il y ait un peu
de
de commerce bien réglementé qui
s'installent là et ça va nécessiter le
renforcement de notre police municipale
et puis pour parler très rapidement des
inondations je ne veux pas parler que de
lens madame ans madame a été inondée 154
fois en un an et demi 154 x voilà
simplement parce qu'on ne fait pas
d'études et qu'on a pas de dispositif
régulier pour enlever le sable et
d'études pour repenser des places pour
éviter que le sable ne revienne je veux
aussi parler de fond l'ail et qui est
inondé quand il ya des épisodes de
pluies importants ce n'est pas normal
que depuis plus de 30 ans une
municipalité n'ait pas lancé une
programmation pluriannuelle des
investissements pour faire 30 m ou 50 m
de protection des berges
chaque année nous ce qui nous intéresse
en jeu vous entendu parler des visiteurs
la vitrine en vitrine c'est bien nous
c'est l'échec girondin d'abord qui nous
intéresse voilà tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à schoelcher depuis 12 ans
n'est pas normal vous êtes habillé pour
le carnaval
à propos de la place des arts à ouaké et
lens madame pas par extension la place
des sahraouis qui finalement n'est pas
totalement terminé la partie de l'autre
côté du pont vers le club nautique de
schoelcher ya pas un projet d'extension
peut-être que je voudrais vous poser un
projet de liaison
cela veut dire que le kid qui n'est pas
carrossable mais qui n'est pas celle qui
n'est pas fait parce que c'est on va
reprendre les choses on va reprendre aux
notes dans l'ordre non on parle de la
wla bien de la place des arts ouais on
est bien d'accord
enfin et son prolongement la place des
arts à wac a été faite par la commune de
schoelcher la deuxième place
vous évoquez été faite par la cassine
les encombrements de la rivière au
niveau du marigot que sa forme
systématiquement c'est quasi
systématique il m'est arrivé plus d'une
fois à titre personnel avec les équipes
municipales avec des élus d'aller des x
4,5 fois dans une journée les bouchers
le marigot une espèce de guéguerre qui
ce qui existe entre eux les services de
l'état la cacem et la commune de
schoelcher mais je vous assure que ce
problème sera réglé
ça c'est une première chose à ses
défauts mais rien qui disait ça c'est
une première chose ça c'est une première
jamais fait l'autre côté mais dans le
lit de la rivière voulait voulu
expliquer mais je voudrais cet homme
parle toujours au futur c'est une
priorité aux 20 fr c'est que je vous
répète à mon retour vers le futur des
attendait non mais moi il ya une
question est là elle a dit qu'elle ne
comprends pas la façon dont ses
messagers de la riviera et ce sont les
deux assemblées
moi je veux des explications j'ai pris
cette rivière elle est ensablé depuis
toujours c'est ouais c'est pas la faute
de mai ou de notre cette rivière oui
elle est depuis toujours mais il faut
agir
c'est fait il faut faire des études il
faut demander à la casse elles font vos
matériels
les travaux qui ont été entamées la
veille le samedi il revient dans la
rivière côté il va mettre côte à côte
alors expliquez nous c'est réel que les
engagements de cette rivière
à chaque fois que l'ouverture est bouché
et fait comme le design est tombé en
dégageant le sable à côté et or
prononçable en laye en l'emmenant
ailleurs que là si comme dit marinette
orpi c'était systématiquement stockées
sur la plage tout le beau seront sable
aujourd'hui ce qui n'est pas le cas
c'est vrai que nous avons eu un petit
souci au niveau des canalisations qui se
divise en arrière à cause de nos
simplement y en aurait un reflux d'eau
qui se fait qu'ils auront dans les
canalisations la cacem a fait des études
sur le sujet et la cacem est en train
d'apporter des solutions à ce problème
et dernière chose que je veux dire là
dessus
lorsqu'on n'a pas d'angle d'attac
vis-à-vis de la mairie les avis de la
gestion actuelle blick municipal on
invente des choses
alors j'entends dire qu'il manque il n'y
a pas keane aucun os qu'aucune mise à
l'eau à schoelcher qu'il y en a au moins
trois que je connaisse
j'entends dire que que les attendait
font la une on mise à l'eau mais si le
fn est eu jeudi un bus qui les fait
quelle méconnaissance un art membre du
directoire
quelle méconnaissance du territoire mais
ce extraordinaire vous confirmez vous
affirmez vous mais c'est moi qui le
pense pas mais j'ai rapidement ensuite
de la promotion lorsque nous sommes
arrivés aux responsabilités toujours
elles sont toujours bien sûr été
emportées entre temps et bien sûr mais
bien sûr c'était fort de chercheurs ont
été abandonnées faux bateliers au fond
là il faut bien penser à bandol et c'est
luc louison terminé son propos il faudra
qu'on passe à autre chose aussi parce
qu'il reste 20 minutes d'émission c'est
à nous mêmes ne met pas tous fassent dix
minutes je comprends pas en accélérant
place un tel contexte qui est décrit par
mes opposants que la population de
chercher la coopération de la martinique
viennent sur deux places et veulent
inviter notre commune je ne comprends
pas c'est une commune qui est
particulièrement sécurisé j'en ai marre
parti dans son introduction tout à leur
rappeler combien cette équipe cette
commune pardon était bien équipé et là
encore mais non c'est je vais je vais me
lâcher je vais pas fait changer je vais
je vais partager avec l'ensemble de mes
prédécesseurs ce qui s'est fait à ce
niveau là je ne vont pas pour moi tout
seul je vais dire également que nous
sommes sur le point de réaliser un grand
projet avec la cacem de revitalisation
de toute la frange littorale de
schoelcher avec pour objectif de
consolider la position balnéaire de la
ville de schoelcher avec la création
d'un équipement sportif qui est en cours
là aujourd'hui qui est en cours faisant
de celle usher une véritable référence
en matière de sport de plage
voilà l'un des projets importants que
nous nourrissons pour cette
particulièrement peut-être démarrer
pêcheurs nous avons démarré je ne savais
pas de pêche qui va commencer très
bientôt autres d'ici quelques semaines
au niveau de la volaille et non mais
faut faire sinon c'est ce que font les
gens sérieux quand ils veulent traiter
un problème conçu une des rivières on
ferait ce qu'on appelle un contrat de
rivière qui permet de réunir l'état
l'europe la cacem pour traiter à la fois
il est question des infrastructures mais
les questions environnementales donc sur
lesquels on sait pas en tout cas
attachés aujourd'hui mais dont je vois
que le maire de se préoccuper peu
puisqu'il est des îles des destinataires
depuis 2013 d'une étude remise par
l'office de l'eau sur la situation de la
rivière parce que qu'on avale de cela
quand la rivière vit mal ça veut dire
que nous nous baignons dans des choses
qui ne sont pas convenables
aujourd'hui aucune de ces 17 disposition
notre mise en oeuvre deuxième chose il
parle de deux fameux projet de
valorisation du littoral
il faut que les auditeurs le sache ce
projet a été lancé en 2008 le projet
lancé en 2008 lui ouvre des solutions en
2020 j'appelle ça allait très bien
franck centre heureusement et pour
vraiment terminer sur ce sujet marinette
torpilles
non on voit mieux mais on voit bien que
kylie à cet immobilisme n'ont pas cet
hymne est ainsi de notre ville on la vit
on la vit on est tous des habitants de
schoelcher sur le clémente et aussi il
ya un vrai mobilise machel chez eux et
moi je l'attribué à l'usure du pouvoir
c'est une certitude moi je crois que
quand on est en campagne depuis 1993 les
écouter c'est normal d'être un peu
fatigué je la tribu aussi au fait de ne
pas toujours se consacrer exclusivement
à sa ville c'est ce que moi je veux
faire marine à torreilles
moi je sais que je voulais dire c'est
sur le littoral tout le littoral de
chercheurs comme certains l'ont dit il
et on est en panne
compass de fond batelière c'est vrai ils
sont délaissés moi je demande aux gens
de fond de batelière si encore ils
votent pour le maire qui est en place il
aime la maltraitance
quand on remonte à madiana madiana rien
c'est une plage ya rien de prévu à
madiana l orienter la clientèle
potentielle
vous remontez comme ça au bo la plage du
bourg il faut faire de l'animation il
faut créer des commerces
il faut faire que nos étudiants viennent
au bo rien n'est fait vous remontez sous
lens matin heureusement qu'on a le club
nautique pour animer un peu ensuite
apprécié
zawawi
nous avons fait la place de lens madame
on a fait des choses ensuite quand on
remonte quand on remonte à près à fond
laillé à lola quartier natal du maire
rien non franchement un équipementier il
on a eu un moment deux mal au dos dames
qu'on a dû les enlever
voici ce qui s'est passé cet hiver alors
bon on fait bon vraiment à fond l'aérien
pareil au siphon dernier pareil jeudi un
moment donné il faut arrêter et je pense
que les chercheurs notamment des fonds
que nous avons fonds d'atelier au fond
des années font l'ail et il faut qu'ils
arrêtent avec la mer traitance est
quelque chose de mer moi c'est mon
message il est clair donc fraction
rapide monsieur hausse à la bono ou pas
des fonds d'atelier au fond la vie parce
qu'il ya une population très importante
en plus un but là sion qui vit là depuis
longtemps ferraillé en 30 a été créée
par les réfugiés de la catastrophe de
1915 sont maintenus donc monsieur
clémente et lointain descendant et donc
si emblématique de la ville je crois que
je crois qu'on parte elle si on ne
partage pas forcément les mêmes méthodes
de travail avec mes concurrents marine
et torpillé daniel chaud mais on partage
le même constat
c'est le constat quasi unanime des
habitants de feltscher notre ville a
besoin de vrais nouveau souffle voilà
oui les quartiers sont abandonnés mais
pas qu'eux font bateliers un pas que
font l'aï pas que font gagner tous les
quartiers sont d'abandonner mon sauf là
c'était sultan ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est insultant devenu nous
lâcher du goudron du béton du
fleurissement à deux mois d'élections et
de dépenser un freak de malades en
l'agent fou à deux mois d'élections pour
essayer de sauver c'est maintenant celui
d'en face alors on est reparti dans ont
terminé en 8 minutes maximum
l'abandon des fonds comme ci comme ça
j'en appelle à schoelcher il fait mais
je suppose que ça ça vous laisse vous
provoque une autre et axa chez vous je
vous répète le cieux jean-marc parti que
lorsqu'on est fan angle d'attaqué et
qu'on réalise que cette commune était
très bien géré et gérant père de famille
on a tendance à exagérer et à tomber
pratiquement dans le mensonge
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit je vous invite
tout simplement je peux même venir vous
chercher pour l'emmener fonds batelière
pour voir ce qui fait dire actuellement
je vous invite à lire avec toi je sais
c'est que je viens de terminer fort
batelière une salle de réunion pour les
jeunes des vestiaires au stade le
football que de déplacés et un immeuble
relative mais pourtant destiné à loger
une vingtaine de personnes 2019
c est ça y est c'est fait c'est terminé
et je vais continuer je vais continuer à
voir la fin de l'émission il ya une
question avant les koalas la série de
conclusions parce que leur odeur des
approches celle cher devrais je parle au
conditionnel obtenir la présidence de la
cacem quel que soit le maire ou la mer
en tout cas c'est ce qui était prévu par
les anciens maire du lamentin à
fort-de-france et de saint joseph qui ne
sont plus en fonction actuellement
est ce que ce serait une bonne chose
pour que chez le chien en deviennent
bénéficiant de cette présidence
tournante entre guillemets c'est une
règle non écrite est je le rappelle
maria ton pays qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ce serait encore égalité j'étais
dans la première mouture de la cancel
disons ça comme ça en 2001 ça avait été
prévu il n'y a pas de raison que celle
ci refuse la présidence daniel chemin
cela me semble naturel que celle cher et
la présidence et quel que soit celui qui
sera maire de chelles cher en tout cas
je souhaiterais de cette position je
regrette cependant qu'on n'ait pas pu
parler de la question des écoles parce
que les situations a dit zico la chair
est très très faible
si vous savez le nombre de sujets que
nous n'avons comme cette explosion oui
cette règle cette règle non écrite
c'était un accord entre les quatre mais
la casse mais je la connais bien j'ai
passé de 2001 à 2007 en tant que
directeur de cabinet de la cacem et
cette règle prévoyait que schelcher
présiderait la cacem en 2014 moi je
regrette que ça ne se soit pas fait à ce
moment là je me battrai pour que celle
cher président de la cacem maintenant je
veux aussi dire que ça se prolonge t il
faut passer à autre chose
c'est un accord équilibré qui permet à
chacun son tour de présider la cacem
mais si cette présidence n'a pas eu lieu
en 2014
c'est aussi parce qu'on est engoncée
dans des arrangements politiciens dont
nous voulons sortir et enfin duc les
matins sur cette question est haute et
je suis d'accord avec mes adversaires le
sujet il faut absolument que c'est le
cheikh adil trouve la présidence avoue
qu'elle n'a pas eu d'occasions mais je
peux pas rentrer dans les polémiques qui
n'apportait rien je vais pas comprendre
ça je dois en vendant ses friands faut
je vais pas entrer dans sa vuvuzela est
président ça revient chez le chien
pointerait al ahly et nous aurons la
présidentielle cher pour les conclusions
bertrand pour wii alors on rappelle que
le tirage au sort justement vous a
désigné lui clémente et non pas pour
commencer les conclusions mais pour
terminer cette séquence donc on va faire
un tour de table et on commence par
marinette torpille vous avez une minute
pour vous adresser directement aux
électrices et ses soeurs de chercheurs
et sinon juste avant la conclusion je
voudrais juste dire ça fait partie de la
conclusion quels que soient les premiers
un peu tout seul but vide universités 1
et on a un vrai problème que je veux
dénoncer c'est le problème des des
étudiants qui ceux qui stationnent
devant le pôle consulaires de chair et
ses étudiants stationnent sur à côté de
la piste cyclable et ses étudiants sont
verbalisés à 135 euros l'amande sur
trois amendes dans le mois et ben on a
franchement on est plombée donc il est
temps que ça s'arrête de foot du alors
non c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
bruit mais il faut que là il faut que la
communauté il faut que la commune la
municipalité soit problème compréhensive
elle les villes universitaires et
l'accueil il faut arrêter de faire de
argent sur le dos la confusion alors ma
conclusion c'est que et pour eux il faut
que pour chercher à qu'il y ait eu maire
qui est de la sincérité qu'il mérite de
l'honnêteté qui eux merck et du coeur et
de la considération pour son prochain et
il faut aussi un mérite et de la
compétence de la connaissance des
affaires communales qui est de
l'expérience pour que 2 a dès son entrée
en fonctions qu'ils puissent actionner
tous les leviers
il faut un maire est une équipe qui est
une stratégie qu une vision qui est un
plan d'action qui correspondent aux
attentes des déchets choix et chercher
noise mon équipe et moi nous répondons à
tous ces critères
notre plan d'action n'est pas fictif il
est tout à fait ambitieux au regard de
ce qu'est la vie de chercheur la people
la population est intégré dans le
fonctionnement interactif que nous
voulons conclure jouer les agents et les
élus formeront le bluff de médecins pour
pouvoir faire que celle cher sera demain
la ville qu'elles étaient il faut nous
virer des chefferies commencé bat merci
marine est ton pays c'est au tour de
daniel le show mais je veux dire très
simplement celle choisie au chinois qu
elle est arrivée les arrivait pouvait
rimer tes ambitions à des politiques
noix les arrivées pour virer m'étais
démocratie à côté c'est mon mail à moi
aussi candidat comme maintenant à côté
le personnel
elle est arrivée pour qu'un nous paie
travail et puis en lots efficacité pour
que l'autre lot chantillac ayant
abandonné à dubaï où vivent et promis
alors il n'y a pas de fatalité en
politique cela doit pouvoir se mesurer
il y a eu un temps le temps de
l'inefficacité
il faut repasser autant de l'ambition au
temps de la solidarité autant de
l'attractivité pour que l'échelle
chinoise retrouve le goût de
l'engagement qu'il retrouve la fierté et
l'amour de leur commune cela nous
pouvons le faire nous devons le faire et
nous allons le faire avec celles et ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui engagés dans une
démarche ambitieuse et cohérente et
partager à côté les chaînes shirwa avec
chercheurs dynamique et daniel chomette
j'aimerais que l'échelle chinoise et les
chercher loin se questionne
eux mêmes elle même sur ce qu'ils
veulent pour eux mêmes pour leur ville
ceux qui trouvent qu'il est suffisant de
présenter un bilan comptable qu'il est
que la situation du personnel est
satisfaisante au voteront pour le
candidat clémente et moi je veux
m'adresser à celles et ceux qui comme
moi estime kocher a besoin d'autre chose
je veux leur dire que le groupe cite
wagne échelle xinhua que je représente
est le seul à proposer de sentir des
vielles pratiques et des cancans
politiciens à se consacrer exclusivement
à schoelcher à redonner vraiment la
parole à ses habitants si vous voulez un
maire qui a de l'expérience je veux un
pdg 50 ans c'est l'âge que notre maire
sortant avait on arrive aux
responsabilités il n'avait pas
contrairement à moi avec tuchan
d'expérience des collectivités
territoriales donc si vous voulez mais
qui a de l'expérience qui va vous
écouter pendant tout le mandat qui va
continuer à être avec vous nouveaux cars
entiers
je vous invite à faire confiance à la
liste citoyens chez xinhua que j'ai
l'honneur de porter et enfin la
conclusion avec clémente et puisque le
tirage au sort nous a désignés pour
terminer cette émission il a fait il a
fallu que le hasard définissent le maire
de celle cher pour conclure je le ferai
donc un plaisir
notre vision pour la ville de schoelcher
s'intitule ensemble pour l'excellence
cette vision est basé sur trois piliers
le premier s'est modernisé le second
développé et le troisième labellisé avec
une priorité forte pour l'aspect
éducatif
nous ferons de l'éducation le moteur de
ces troisièmes ma nature en faisant en
sorte que les enfants de celle cher
puisqu'en quittant le cm2 sache parler
certaines langues étrangères en ce
moment d'arrêt notamment sache également
maîtriser la langue des signes
saches maîtriser les gestes de premiers
secours et une conscience écologique
forte et maîtrise le numérique nous
voulons faire en sorte que le bourg de
schoelcher connaissent une grande
revitalisation qui sortent de fond l'ail
et de fond dernier pendant écart à la
batelière
je l'aï dit à l'instant je pars ou
détaillé nous voulons mettre en place un
territoire d'excellence six secondes au
niveau de la vie au niveau 2
du quartier la démarche côté faire de la
démarche un territoire d'excellence
rurale et nous voulons aussi faire de
celle cher une ville très connectée jeu
dernier mot il ya les mots je voudrais
dire que être maire c'est aussi
s'occuper du quotidien
on a très peu parlé du quotidien je veux
dire que de ce point de vue la chaîne
cher
l'actuelle mini l'actuelle équipe
municipale a mis beaucoup d'oeuvres à la
tâche de faire en sorte de chercher à
jouer à fait notablement une ville je
souhaite y ait une question vous avez
adoubé franck sainte-rose rosemont lors
d'un débat soyez tout ça parce que j'ai
vu une photo qui circule on vous voit le
bras sur l'épaule de et je crois que ce
candidat dit que vous l'avez en quelque
sorte un petit peu à tout j'accueille
avec plaisir cette passation mais il
s'est dépêché de répondre avant moi mais
le loto héritage
je sais pas très citoyen tout ça va
faire le maillot rose a choisi son camp
on va dire ça comme ça
il a choisi son camp je revienne avant
que jean bart pour précise les prochains
rendez vous sur nos antennes télé et
radio web jeu cette émission a été
réalisée par un chef chez roy d'ailleurs
paul-eric tout ça soleil était aux
manettes technique au 10 de l'étape à la
voile à rodrigues n'était pas le cas ce
n'est pas loin un autre chef chez roy
les rendez vous à venir oui juste pour
appeler un qui vient c'est quand même
17000 électrices et électeurs à chercher
où ils vont mettre tout le monde
d'accord le 15 et où le 22 mars
le chronométrage de l'émission était
assurée par michel joseph qui a obtenu
un rôle très important et qui madame
monsieur nous as you que le temps
paroles sont équilibrés donc nous
pouvons nous référer à son expertise
les prochains rendez vous ce sera déjà
ce lundi 17 février avec les candidats
de cette swim et oui voilà
nous allons dans le sud mardi 4 le
lendemain ce sont ces lévisien avec les
candidats du vauclin avec une émission
présentée par christine cuppitt et frank
zorn et nous nous retrouvons vendredi
prochain radio avec le candidat du
transit les voilà merci pour votre
attention votre fidélité à bientôt
[Musique]